BRET: THE SINGAPORE FERRIS WHEEL
JUST AROUND THE BLOCK FROM WHERE
WE ARE.
TAKES ABOUT 30 MINUTES TO GET
AROUND.
NO PLANS FOR THE LEADERS TO TAKE
A SPIN.
THE SUMMIT OF COURSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S MOMENT TO SHINE.
BUT IT IS ALSO CASTING A SPOT
LIGHT ON THE MAN WHO IS
AMERICA'S TOP DIPLOMAT.
STATE MIKE POMPEO, FROM
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON ALSO
HERE IN SINGAPORE.
>> HE'S TWICE MET THE LEADER NO
SITTING AMERICAN PRESIDENT HAS.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
HAS SPENT SHOWERS WITH NORTH
KOREAN DICTATOR KIM JONG-UN.
>> HE HAS INDICATED TO ME
PERSONALLY THAT HE IS PREPARED
TO DENUCLEARIZE.
THAT HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
CURRENT MODEL DOESN'T WORK.
>> BEFORE THE SENATE EVEN
CONFIRMED HIM AS SECRETARY OF
STATE, MIKE POMPEO LED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S DIPLOMACY
TOWARDS NORTH KOREA.
SECRETLY TRAVELLING TO PYONGYANG
EASTER WEEKEND AS CIA DIRECTOR
AND AGAIN WEEKS AFTER ARRIVING
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
THROUGH THOSE CONVERSATIONS HE
SAYS HE BELIEVED KIM JONG-UN
UNDERSTANDS BOTH COUNTRIES HAVE
TO TAKE BOLD STEPS TO ACHIEVE A
HISTORIC OUTCOME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SURROUNDED BY
DIVERSE OPINIONS ON NORTH KOREA.
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR WHO IN
FEBRUARY WROTE IN THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL," QUOTE, THE
LEGAL CASE FOR STRIKING NORTH
KOREA FIRST.
JOHN BOLTON ALSO ARGUED NORTH
KOREA SHOULD DISARM AS LIBYA
DID, SURRENDER ITS NUCLEAR
PROGRAM IN ITS ENTIRETY UP
FRONT.
SECRETARY POMPEO HAS DETAILED A
MUCH MORE NUANCED APPROACH.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OUTSIDE
ATTORNEY DESCRIBED KIM JONG-UN
AFTER THE APPARENT CANCELLATION
OF THIS SUMMIT.
>> KIM JONG-UN GOT BACK ON HIS
HANDS AND KNEES AND BEGGED FOR
IT.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO DISMISSED
>> WE ARE MOVING FORWARD,
FOCUSING ON THE IMPORTANT
THINGS.
I KNOW RUDY -- RUDY DOESN'T
SPEAK FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NEGOTIATION
AND THIS SET OF ISSUES.
>> A SENIOR STATE OFFICIAL SAYS
SECRETARY POMPEO SPEAKS WITH THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THIS SOMETIMES
SEVERAL TIMES A DAY AND THEY
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
SINCE THE PRESIDENT TOOK OFFICE.
POMPEO SAYS KIM IS ALSO
PREPARED.
>> HE KNOWS HIS BRIEF.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE FOR THE NORTH KOREAN
PEOPLE.
HE'S ABLE TO DEAL WITH
COMPLEXITY WHEN THE CONVERSATION
REQUIRES IT.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO ARRIVED IN
SINGAPORE WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
ON BOARD AIR FORCE ONE.
HE LEAVES ALONE, TRAVELING TO
SEOUL IN BEIJING, TO UPDATE
REGIONAL ALLIES AND ADVERSARIES
OF WHATEVER THE PRESIDENT AND
KIM ACCOMPLISHED HERE.